und sie können live dabei sein hier bei
heute plus im fernsehen und außerdem in
unserem live stream im netz
guten abend ich freue mich dass sie
dabei sind was wird sich um mitternacht
für die briten ändern aber auch für den
rest europas das ordnung der mit unserem
korrespondenten ein
wir schauen direkt auf die straßen
londons ein grund zur freude oder einen
tag der tiefen trauer die meinungen
liegen ja heute weit auseinander
andrea stammen steht für uns auf dem
parliament square mitten in der
menschenmenge umgeben von breck cities
in partystimmung andreas was ist da los
bei dir ja hier spricht gerade eitel
verarscht der vater des wechsels
sozusagen und das ist eine unglaublich
große party geworden ist war nass kalt
regnerisch windig den ganzen tag also
niemand hat damit gerechnet dass es so
voll wird aber es ist voll die praxis
befürworter die wollen feiern heute
normalerweise ist london ja sehr
proeuropäisch heute gehört dieser platz
findet ihr sie haben dreieinhalb jahre
gewartet sie haben immer gesagt wir
wollen nicht dass uns dieser sieg im
referendum noch gestohlen wird auf den
letzten metern und das ist irre partie
heute abend und ich kann versprechen
dass wird hier gleich um 12 deutscher
zeit um 23 uhr britischer zeit richtig
richtig laut und es wird glaube ich auch
sehr emotional
die bresche gegner die haben sich
verkrümelt wir wollen nicht dabei sein
wenn die praxis ihren triumph feiern
heute nacht dank andreas dahmen wir
schalten auf jeden fall noch mal gegen
mitternacht zu dir doch nicht überall
wird heute gefeiert großbritannien ist
ein gespaltenes land triumph auf der
einen frust auf der anderen seite noch
mal zur erinnerung nur eine hauchdünne
mehrheit der briten stimmt im juni 2016
für den austritt
nun wird sich das lager der brh exit
gegner endgültig an den gedanken
gewöhnen müssen dass die mitgliedschaft
in der eu geschichte ist wie der brachse
tag heute verlief zeigt ja sie nie
allein
ein letztes mal noch standen sie sich
gegenüber brad pitt befürworter und
praxis gegner
heute morgen im regierungsviertel und
auf dem parliament square jenem platz
vor dem parlament in dem in den letzten
dreieinhalb jahren so viele bereits
schlachten geschlagen wurden die
regierung war ausgeflogen ihre
kabinettssitzung hielt sie heute ins
sauerland ab symbolträchtig war es doch
diese stadt im norden englands die sich
in der referendums nacht als erste für
den austritt ausgesprochen hatte am
späten abend dann veröffentlichte der
premierminister via facebook eine video
nachricht an die nation in der er
betonte dass es seine aufgabe und die
seine regierung sei das land zu einen
und in die zukunft zu führen
versöhnlich sollte das klingen bloß
keine allzu triumphalen töne aufkommen
lassen so das motto doch für jene die
gerne in der eu geblieben während ist
das ein schwacher trost wenn das
referendum damals fair und ordentlich
ausgetragen worden wäre hätte ich das
akzeptiert aber so bin ich jetzt einfach
wahnsinnig wütend ich möchte der
europäischen kommission danken für alles
was sie für uns in den letzten jahren
getan haben millionen von menschen in
diesem land wollen in der eu bleiben und
eines tages werden wir zurückkehren da
bin ich mir sicher
und wahrlich nicht überall ist der
widerstand gegen den br- exit gänzlich
gebrochen
zum beispiel in schottland wo die
dortige erste ministerin ein
unabhängigkeitsreferendum und den
wiedereintritt in die eu plant eine neue
50 pence gedenkmünze zum eu-austritt
propagiert frieden wohlstand und
freundschaft mit allen nationen klingt
doch net jetzt darf man gespannt sein ob
der berec sieht das auch wirklich
einlöst und unsere studioleiterin in
london diana zimmermann steht nicht in
der menschenmenge sondern hat heute im
doppelten sinn der den überblick über
das geschehen diana
was wird sich denn nun um mitternacht
unmittelbar für die briten verändern
[Musik]
erst mal gar nichts sie werden davon
nichts merken aber sie sind natürlich
tatsächlich nicht mehr mitglied in der
europäischen union sie haben kein
mitspracherecht mehr
und was jetzt geschieht morgen beginnt
die übergangsphase also genau genommen
in den wenigen minuten
und die hält an bis ende des jahres 2020
in dieser zeit werden die briten von den
veränderungen nicht spüren
es laufen die verhandlungen und die
sollen ende 2020 mit einem
freihandelsvertrag enden wie der dann
aussieht allerdings weiß momentan noch
niemand und insofern ist es eine bizarre
situation dass hier heute abend wird
gefeiert wird ohne dass eigentlich
irgendjemand weiß was dann in zukunft
passiert vielen dank diana für die
einordnung und wir schauen noch einmal
auf den countdown in der downing street
in wenigen minuten tritt großbritannien
aus der eu aus und wir wollen die zeit
nutzen um kurz darauf zu schauen was
sonst noch wichtig es auf der welt
passiert ist im us senat steht das
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen präsident
trump vor dem aus vor wenigen minuten
hat der senat dagegen gestimmt weitere
zeugen anzuhören
im demokraten wollten den ehemaligen
sicherheitsberater john boten befragen
die mehrheit der republikaner
verhinderte das aber jetzt könnte das so
genannte impeachment verfahren schon in
den nächsten tagen mit einem freispruch
des präsidenten in bayern hat sich zum
ersten mal ein kind mit dem corona virus
infiziert hat sich bei seinem vater
angesteckt der zu den ersten infizierten
in deutschland gehörte die familie wurde
in einem krankenhaus isoliert
insgesamt gibt es damit jetzt sieben
infizierte in deutschland
die usa haben den gesundheitsnotstand
ausgerufen
ab sonntag gilt ein einreiseverbot für
nicht us bürger die sich in den
vergangenen zwei wochen in china
aufgehalten haben
flüge aus china dürfen dann nur noch an
sieben flughäfen landen
in australien ist die brandkatastrophe
noch nicht überstanden ein riesiges
feuer in einem nationalpark bedroht die
hauptstadt canberra
die regierung hat für die region den
notstand ausgerufen damit im ernstfall
schnell evakuiert werden kann
20.000 hektar wald sind dort schon
zerstört am wochenende soll es bis zu 40
grad heiß werden regen ist
eine einsicht und die immer freitags
außerdem noch die zahlen des euro
jackpots und die lauten 17 12 23 39 und
die euro zahlen 3 und 4
alle angaben wie immer ohne gewähr und
jetzt werfen wir noch mal einen kurzen
blick auf die uhr auf den countdown in
der downing street in wenigen minuten
tritt großbritannien aus der eu aus und
damit schalten wir jetzt live zu andrea
stammen wer immer noch mitten auf dem
parliament square in london steht
andreas steigt die spannung langsam
ja das ist ein bisschen wie public
viewing beim fußball wm finale so kommt
es einem vor also hier geht es gleich
richtig rund und ich habe allen neben
mir allen kommt aus escher in schottland
ist ein fischer und damit eine sehr
ungewöhnliche kombination warum ein
fischer aus schottland für den bhc rexit
frische man vom scotland boarding brett
kontakt deutschland kommt von
lieferservice.de willkommen
vertriebsprozess wollen selbst keine
thermik und 19 am ende juli in julie
julia ist im bereich public key market
officer cro freunde european juni
verlässt 1 des starensembles beim
kinderfasching annemarie börlind denis
leary malaysia costa communitys also
allen ich fasse mal zusammen sagt
phishing war das was sie geopfert haben
beim eintritt in die europäische union
und jetzt wollen sie eben die kontrolle
zurück ist es ein bisschen symbolisch
und deswegen hat er vor dem rexit
gestimmt für die fischereiindustrie dass
sie eben außerhalb der eu neu aufblühen
kann und ich glaube jetzt kommen wir
ziemlich nahe an den moment auf den die
praxis befürworter die sich hier heute
versammelt haben dreieinhalb jahre
gewartet haben sie habe darauf
hingefiebert sie hatten auch die
hoffnung verloren
man kann da jetzt zu stehen wie man will
aber klar sie hatten einen sieg im
referendum und den wollen sollten sie
eigentlich schon lange umgesetzt sehen
und jetzt ist es so bei den wenigen
minuten
countdown läuft eine minute sagt nigel
farage der da auf der bühne steht
wir sind hier so eingekeilt von leuten
wir können da kaum können da kaum rein
kommen wir versuchen zwar aber es ist
ein historischer moment da ist überhaupt
keine frage ob man im rexit nun ablehnen
domain befürwortet ob es einem egal ist
es ist nach 47 jahren das erste mal dass
ein land der europäischen union verletzt
67 jahre mitglied der europäischen union
und jetzt geht an land vielleicht eine
zeitenwende und wir haben mal rein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was man da ist nicht der original widmen
da wird restauriert die praxis wollten
das waren heute abend mit
das ging aus vielerlei gründen nicht zu
teuer und so schwierig jetzt kommt der
band geben vom band
[Musik]
und man darf sich bei den bildern
natürlich auch keine illusion hingeben
dass jetzt hier überall in
großbritannien gefeiert wird das ist die
eine hälfte der bevölkerung die andere
hälfte der bevölkerung die heute abend
hier nicht mehr ist sie gegangen ist
diesen bieten
mutlos traurig manche auch trotzig und
versuchen irgendwie einen weg wieder
zurück zu finden in diese eu aber
erstmal ist großbritannien draußen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
god save the queen sind die königin die
nationalhymne natürlich der vorwurf
immer dass es auch eine sehr
nationalistische agenda ist wie hier
vertreten wurde keine frage viele
praxistipps sagen immer wir verlassen
die eu aber nicht europa aber
fairerweise muss man sagen das sind auch
viele ressentiments dabei und es wurde
heute auch viel darüber diskutiert hier
auf dem platz
wer vielleicht nachfolgt wer als
nächster eu fall es also viele hier
wollen vielleicht auch dass die eu ganz
verschwindet also es ist nicht ganz ganz
ganz ohne ist das hier heute nicht
[Musik]
ich habe es ja youtube so gern
ingenhoven dies hier fribourg ein baby
deutschland wird also keine frage er ist
total glücklich es ist eben der beginn
eines übergangs eines neuen zeitalters
für ihn und er ist happy hier wird heute
glaube ich die nacht zum tag gemacht und
es wird eine lange rauschende nacht ob
dann ein kater erfolg ob dieser triumph
nicht doch noch in einer tragödie
geendet die für großbritannien für
europa das wird sich erst ab morgen
zeiten und vielen dank andreas stamm für
diese eindrücke und von den emotionen
wechseln wir jetzt zu den knallharten
zahlen und fakten der brh exit ist nicht
nur das ende einer ära sondern auch ein
anfang nämlich von zähen verhandlungen
aber einiges wird der eu auch direkt
schon fehlen
jochen spieß berichtet der exit jetzt
ist er da fast vier jahre nach dem
referendum und drei premierminister
später verlassen 66,2 millionen
britinnen und treten die europäische
union
damit rutscht die eu insgesamt unter die
halbe milliarde einwohner
auch die 73 britischen abgeordneten im
eu-parlament sagten diese woche wird bei
jeder zehnte eu-abgeordnete durch den
dreck cit verliert europa zudem seine
zweitgrößte volkswirtschaft 2,4
millionen euro hatte zuletzt das
bruttoinlandsprodukt betragen
der ist united kingdom hatte so einen
anteil von etwa 15 prozent am
bruttoinlandsprodukt der eu
zugleich war das vereinigte königreich
der zweitgrößte nettozahler der eu
knapp sieben milliarden zahlten sie
zuletzt mehr ein als sie herausbekommen
nur wir deutschen brachten unter dem
strich noch mehr ein
nicht nur die insel auf der anderen
seite des ärmelkanals rückt von uns ab
auch wichtige seegebiete drum herum
gehören da nicht mehr zur eu nahezu 100%
des nordsee herings den wir essen wurden
bisher vor der britischen küste gefangen
auch von deutschen fischer doch es
bleibt noch zeit bis die praxistür
tatsächlich zu fällt bis zum 31 12 2020
wird das vereinigte königreich
wirtschaftlich noch wie ein eu-land
gehandelt solange können also noch alle
ohne schranken hierunter arbeiten und
wohnen
erst danach sollen die neuen regelungen
rund um den brad pitt beschlossen sein
und in kraft treten der praxis lässt
sich auch jetzt noch zeit auch auf die
eu kommt also viel arbeit zu schalten
wir live zu anne gellinek nach brüssel
an
was sind aus sicht der eu die härtesten
brocken die noch verhandelt werden
müssen
ja ich muss dir kurz erst erklären was
sich hier abspielt ich steh vom
europaparlament und links von mir rechts
von dir siehst du die fahnen master und
da haben sich hier menschen versammelt
weil sie dabei sein wollten wie der juni
in jack eingeholt wird zusammengefaltet
und ins haus der europäischen geschichte
gebracht wird aber die ju hat den
menschen die sich hier versammelt haben
eigentlich um zu trauern das sind kaum
leute hier die feiern wollen sondern ist
eher ein ausdruck der solidarität mit
den briten die uhr den menschen ein
schnippchen geschlagen indem sie den
juni entdeckt nämlich schon heute abend
um kurz vor 8 1 geholt hat und jetzt
wird hier die eu fahren aber die
menschen feiern trotzdem zu deiner frage
es gibt natürlich viele harte brocken in
diesen verhandlungen aber einer ist
besonders symbolträchtig und das sind
die fischereirechte die gerade auch im
beitrag schon mal angesprochen wurden
wolfs johnson hat ja seinen fischern
seinen britischen fischern versprochen
dass sie wieder die kontrolle bekommen
würden über die britischen gewässer und
sich fortan nicht mehr über fangquoten
streiten müssten mit
in europäischen fischern dieses aber ist
ein versprechen das er wahrscheinlich so
nicht halten kann denn die frage die die
ju stellt ist lieber boris johnson wo
wollen sie denn den fisch denen ihre
fischer künftig aus der nordsee holen
werden wo wollen sie den denn verkaufen
natürlich will boris johnson den in der
eu verkaufen und deshalb sagt die eu
dann müssen unsere fischer auch
weiterhin zugangsrechte zu britischen
gewässern haben
ansonsten wären die arbeitsplätze der
fischverarbeitenden industrie in
großbritannien gefährdet das wird gold
stanzen boris johnson wohl nicht
riskieren wollen das ist nur ein punkt
ein symbolträchtiger ein wichtiger
weiterer punkt sind die britischen
finanzdienstleistungen die
landwirtschaft also dass werden
langwierige schwierige verhandlungen wie
verändert sich denn die eu jetzt wohne
die briten die waren ja schon immer ein
stück weit auch die nörgler in der eu
könnte das jetzt deutschlands rolle
werden also der schwarze peter geht
ziemlich deutlich richtung deutschland
denn es war ja so dass die briten immer
die front der sparer der geizkragen was
das eu-budget anbetraf angeführt hat und
dass sich viele nordeuropäischen länder
und oft auch deutschland hinter dem
rücken der briten versteckt haben wenn
die briten jetzt weg sind müssen die
alle aus der deckung kommen viele
nordeuropäer also die ihren zb die
niederländer die dänen schauen jetzt auf
deutschland und sagen ihr seid jetzt der
größte nettozahler jetzt müsst ihr es
machen jetzt müsst ihr den südländern
die größere eu fördertöpfe und größere
investitionen wollen aus öffentlichen
mitteln
jetzt müsst ihr den sagen dass das nicht
geht also deutschland wird er eine
deutlich unbequemere rolle in zukunft
haben
vielen dank anne gellinek nach brüssel
großbritannien und die europäische union
diese beziehung lief nicht immer und
schon der anfang war so muss man sagen
ähnlich sehe wie jetzt das ende
drei anläufe hat es damals gebraucht bis
die briten endlich bei treten durften
auch sonst gab es immer wieder ups and
downs und die briten betten nun ja immer
ganz eigene wege
jassim herrlein wirft einen blick zurück
auf 47 jahre mitgliedschaft
die trümmer des zweiten weltkriegs waren
noch nicht weggeräumt als kein
geringerer als winston churchill für ein
vereintes europa war zudem jedoch
großbritannien nicht zwingend dazu
gehören musste in den 60ern wollten sie
dann aber doch mitmachen general de
gaulle gleichwohl befand das würde nicht
so gut passen die denke der
inselbewohner sei irgendwie anders
der mann sollte recht behalten trotzdem
sicherte sich großbritannien 1973
letztlich seinen platz an der
europäischen tafel um das zwei jahre
später in einem referendum gleich wieder
infrage zu stellen
das hatte der labour-premier prinzen
versprochen wer ordentlich links war auf
der insel war gegen europa die
konservativen dafür allen voran margaret
thatcher wie sich an diesem schicken
pulli unschwer erkennen lässt den trug
sie allerdings nur in der referendums
kampagne die mit großer mehrheit
gewonnen wurde
danach machte die eiserne lady ihren
amtskollegen vom festland das leben
schwer
sie erzwang den sogenannten briten
rabatt und zu mehr macht für das
europäische parlament die kommission und
den ministerrat sagte sie nur
[Applaus]
zetsches nachfolger john major hatte in
auggen viele zwar die ausstrahlung eines
sparkassendirektors bei einem thema aber
konnte der konservative premier richtig
leidenschaftlich werden gegen harten
widerstand boxte er die
maastricht-verträge durchs unterhaus vor
allem gegen den der baarstadt die major
die euro skeptiker in seiner partei
nannte und die gewannen nicht nur bei
den konservativen ganz allmählich die
oberhand in brüssel spielten die briten
immer seltener mit nicht beim schengener
abkommen zum freien grenzverkehr und
auch beim euro nicht die uk independence
party wurde eigens mit dem ziel
gegründet das land vom eu noch zu
befreien als das mit dem sieg im
referendum von 2016 dann fast erreicht
war legte youtube-chef neues fahrrad im
europaparlament verbal gleich nochmal
nach als ich vor 17 jahren hierher kam
und sagte ich wollte eine kampagne
anführen die eu zu verlassen habt ihr
mich alle ausgelacht jetzt ist euch das
lachen vergangen
das muss man dem anlassen wirklich
lustig ist das alles zuletzt ja nicht
gewesen
und das war es von heute bloß für heute
hier im fernsehen wir senden jetzt im
netz noch ein bisschen weiter also wenn
sie fragen haben zum wechselt dann
wechseln sie am besten direkt zu unserem
live stream in die zdf mediathek zu
youtube facebook oder twitter
das wirklich freuen und hier im stream
soll es jetzt um ihre kommentare und
ihre fragen gehen und ein bisschen was
hat sich davon schon hier auf meinem
bildschirm zusammengesammelt live
zugeschaltet ist mir jetzt diana
zimmermann und diana also eine frage die
ich hier ganz spannend fand kommt bei
facebook von gregor adler und der fragt
lohnt sich das alles eigentlich für die
briten
ja das ist natürlich die entscheidende
frage
es kommt darauf an wie man das berechnen
will finanziell wird es sich vermutlich
mittelfristig nicht lohnen alle gehen
davon aus dass das wirtschaftswachstum
großbritanniens nicht nur in den letzten
jahren wie wir
belegen können geschrumpft ist sondern
auch in den kommenden jahren deutlich
geringer sein wird als es normalerweise
gewesen wäre
finanziell wird es also wahrscheinlich
keine plus rechnung aber hier geht es
natürlich um was anderes
hier geht es um nationalstolz um
identität um das gefühl frei zu sein tun
und lassen zu können was man will und in
dieses gefühl hat die praxis kampagne
von anfang an eingezahlt und nun erntet
sie heute die zukünftigen beziehungen
zwischen der eu und großbritannien
aussehen muss ja noch verhandelt werden
an welcher stelle könnte es dann da
schwierig werden da wird es an sehr
vielen stellen schwierig da geht es um
viele details bisher ging es ja nur so
um die großen züge des austritts jetzt
geht es aber in handels verhandlungen
und die sind bekanntermaßen
ausgesprochen kompliziert alle versuchen
alles miteinander zu verschachern und
die große schwierigkeit die insgesamt
hier besteht ist dass großbritannien
eben abwägen muss was machen sie mit
dieser freiheit die heute abend hier
gefeiert wurde
was fangen sie damit an wollen sie die
wirklich voll ausnutzen wollen sie sich
wirklich von allen eu vorschriften
lossagen und versuchen das alleine zu
stemmen
dann sagt brüssel werden wir kein enges
handelsabkommen mit euch abschließen
können dann seid ihr ein konkurrent der
mit anderen mitteln spielt und wir
wollen einen solchen konkurrenten nicht
vor der haustüre haben dann wird der
zugang zum europäischen binnenmarkt
deutlich beschnitten werden oder aber
großbritannien großbritannien versucht
eben doch auch gewisse freiheiten zu
verzichten sich weiterhin am
arbeitnehmerrechten an umweltschutz oder
an steuerrecht der europäischen union zu
orientieren
dann sagt brüssel können wir weiter
gehen in diesem freihandelsabkommen um
diese dinge geht es und dann geht es
noch um so symbolisches wie die
fischereipolitik von der wir heute schon
gehört haben also eine frage die hier in
den kommentaren vorkommt ist die nach
der reisefreiheit hier fragt zum
beispiel den usa
wie sieht das mit einem wieso sie visum
aus brauche ich das schon ab morgen oder
erst nach ende der frist also ab morgen
brauchen wir gar nichts ab morgen ändert
sich erst mal hier überhaupt nichts die
übergangsfrist endet am 31 januar 2020
und es steht nicht fest was dann
passiert ich halte es aber für extrem
unwahrscheinlich dass tatsächlich visa
benötigt werden um von der eu nach
großbritannien zu reisen
höchstens eben dass man so was wie eine
arbeitsgenehmigung brauchen wird wenn
man hier arbeiten möchte vielen dank die
an hat sich mal nach london
und wir schalten jetzt direkt vor anne
gellinek nach brüssel weiter an
nun hat sich ja heute auch die
kommissionschefin ursula von der leyen
geäußert und hat deutliche signale nach
london gesendet müssen sich die briten
da auf harte verhandlungen einstellen
also zumindest hat die eu kommission
heute diesen diesen eindruck versucht zu
erwecken das war sicherlich ist
natürlich auch teil des spiels dass
beide seiten am anfang sie wollen ja
beide am montag ihr verhandlungsmandat
öffentlich machen dass beide seiten
natürlich vorher erstmal fronten
aufbauen und sagen wir lassen uns nicht
von den anderen klein kriegen aber sie
war freundlich im ton aber sie hat doch
ganz deutlich klar gemacht dass boris
johnson nicht damit rechnen kann dass er
irgendwelche vergünstigungen
irgendwelche rosinenpicken in sachen
winden markt bekommen könnte sondern
dass das ganze streng auf
gegenseitigkeit beruht wenn bohren
stanzen zugeständnisse macht bei den
standards bei der anlehnung an
eu-standard dann wird er genau so viel
zugang zum markt bekommen
wenn nicht wird er vom binnenmarkt
ausgeschlossen hier kommt eine frage bei
youtube von neo und zwar nach den
wirtschaftlichen konsequenzen
welche wirtschaftlichen folgen wird der
brh exit haben für deutschland und die
eu und ich würde mal hinzufügen die
frage unser finanzminister hat sich
jetzt gerade erst bei in davos dazu
geäußert und gesagt deutschland wird
oder auch die eu wird besser wegkommen
als großbritannien
wie wird auf eingeschätzt also so genau
weiß das natürlich keiner das sind ja
immer sehr viele spekulationen aber man
hat schon den eindruck dass die
europäische union mit einem gewissen
selbstbewusstsein in diese verhandlungen
geht sie sagt natürlich ist der brh exit
für alle seiten schlecht er ist sowohl
für die britische seite schlecht als
auch für die europäische aber er ist
noch schlechter für die briten als für
die europäer und russen
ein hat heute sogar gesagt dass wenn die
verhandlungen scheitern würden über ein
freihandelsabkommen und man eben über
diese klippe springen müsste am 31
dezember und sagen müsste wir machen
einen harten bretone jeden deal dann sei
das immer noch eine situation die besser
handelbar seit für die europäische union
als für die briten aber natürlich ist es
so dass die autoindustrie in deutschland
und die landwirtschaft in frankreich
natürlich wollen alle weiter handel
treiben und insofern kann man auch sagen
dass jetzt im moment erstmal der preis
hochgetrieben wird für die verhandlung
das ist ein bisschen wie bei
tarifverhandlungen jede seite beharrt
erstmal darauf dass sie auf jeden fall
harte positionen aufbauen will und ob es
dann in den verhandlungen so kommt ob
die eu wirklich so prinzipienfest dann
in den verhandlungen bleibt das werden
wir sehen mit der europäischen
wirtschaft die ihr im nacken sitzt eine
frage die hier noch bei youtube gestellt
wurde gibt es denn irgendeinen weg für
die briten noch zurück ja den gibt es
wenn sie am 31 dezember dieses jahres
ausscheiden und sozusagen als dritt
stark nochmal drittstaat noch mal von
vorne anfangen dann können sie natürlich
wie jedes andere land auch einen antrag
auf beitrittsverhandlungen stellen und
sozusagen diesen prozess wieder von
vorne anfangen der würde natürlich bei
einem beitrittskandidaten wie
großbritannien sehr viel schneller gehen
als dass zum beispiel in nord mazedonien
oder mit albanien der fall wäre
weil die große x die briten ja eben
schon sehr sehr viele eu standards oder
alle eu-standards eigentlich übernommen
haben aber das ist natürlich sehr
unrealistisch dass jetzt der prozess
noch zu stoppen ist ist eigentlich nicht
mehr möglich denn der artikel 50 kann
jetzt glaube ich nicht mehr zurück
gezogen werden da der prozess des
austritts läuft der austritt ist ja
formell vorzogen jetzt gibt es noch die
übergangsphase für die künftigen
beziehungen jetzt bleibt nur noch der
neu beitritt großbritanniens und
er ist glaube ich im moment nicht sehr
wahrscheinlich vielen dank an die klinik
nach brüssel und wir schalten jetzt noch
einmal nach london zu andreas stamm da
gab es ja gerade ein bisschen bild und
ton probleme wir hoffen dass das jetzt
nicht passiert andreas wie es denn jetzt
die stimmung mittlerweile ein bisschen
gelehrt muss man sagen und mir ist etwas
gelungen was ich nicht geglaubt hätte
ich habe männer gefunden leute die das
ihr in diesem rexit party befürworter
überschwang irgendwie ein bisschen doof
finden und dann auch noch aus
deutschland denn das hilft mir das
lästig übersetzen irgendwie nicht machen
zu müssen und zwar habe ich tee und
floriert eu kommt dass leipzig flow
arbeitet hier seit fünf jahren in london
was familie hier was sagst du heute ja
also erstmal will ich natürlich
irgendwie traurig ich glaube sowie eine
viele von uns die die großbritannien
gerne weiter in der eu gesehen hätten
andererseits müssen wir nach vorne
schauen und auch können jetzt wieder
darüber anfangen zu reden dass sie
großbritannien irgendwann wieder eu
beitritt muss ja irgendwie auch
irgendwie eine version und blick nach
vorne haben also ein bisschen trotz
dabei jetzt halt eben okay wir haben
diese politische niederlage kassiert
aber das ist nicht das ende der
geschichte
trotz ist dabei ich mein politischer wir
halten nichts zu sagen gehabt wir
durften ja nicht abstimmen durften nicht
wählen sondern waren passiver beobachter
dieses des ganzen prozesses und wir
müssen uns jetzt vielleicht auch
überlegen was die konsequenzen des
ganzen sind und ob wir jetzt in
großbritannien bleiben steht noch auf
dem anderen zettel so
seid ihr happy wie großbritannien das
handelt mit den rechten der eu bürger
wie das ist mit dem zettel stakes klima
so wer kann hier bleiben wie das alles
läuft seit er da happy mit oder seht da
auch dass die eu noch ein bisschen mehr
dampf machen muss dass das hier
ordentlich läuft denn die verhandlungen
laufen ja weiter zufrieden bin ich damit
nicht habe angefangen mich dafür zu
bewerben und der prozess war einfach
ziemlich kompliziert da so online und
mit meinem pass nicht einlesen können
und ich muss das erstmal noch die tage
machen aber ein bisschen mehr druck aus
brüssel wäre auf jeden fall gut theodor
bis zu besuch ist als
katastrophentourismus
nein ich schweige für die größere idee
das muss erläutern flagge auf halbmast
also man sieht ganz deutlich die wenigen
männer die wenigen die sozusagen den
drechselt ablehnen die sind heute
natürlich traurig die sind auch ein
bisschen mutlos aber auch eben bereit
wie energie dieser praxis auch
mobilisiert hat überhaupt keine frage
denn das sind große pandas lappert er
also hin so politikmüdigkeit und dann
kam dieser praxis und hat mobilisiert
politisiert hat das land gespalten und
die eine hälfte die heute abend eben
eingestehen musste okay wir haben es
nicht geschafft in brechts zu verhindern
die vielen vielleicht auch diese energie
nutzen um in zukunft einfach dafür zu
arbeiten dass es wieder einen weg gibt
mit großbritannien wieder vielleicht
zurück an den brüsseler tisch kommen
kann
das ist jetzt wirklich zukunftsmusik
mittel und langfristig heute ist der tag
des brh exit die briten sind raus und
daran werden die männer ein wenig zu
knabbern haben und die black city es der
platz leert sich so langsam die
wahrscheinlich in pubs in zügen auf dem
weg nach hause oder sonstwo noch
ordentlich weiter feiern
aber das wichtigste ist es ist friedlich
geblieben und die polizei hat ganz gut
im griff aber das kennt man eigentlich
aus london
vielen dank andreas stamm an diesem
historischen tag für diese eindrücke
und das war es von heute plus vielen
dank für die vielen fragen und
kommentare und fürs zu sehen natürlich
auch ich wünsche ihnen ein schönes
wochenende
tschüss
[Musik]